hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
what my readers wissam who was asking me
I'm a currently system analyst nothing
related to human resources I can feel
the low trust levels in my organization
between co-workers and sometimes
employees in a management what's the
impact that load trust in an
organization and what can we do to
change it so what Sam first of all I
want to congratulate you for taking an
interest in the business that you
working on a lot of people they felt low
trust levels that just jump off and
wouldn't want to try to improve it they
may be go look for another job so that
comment you be trying really hard to
keep you there because you're trying to
make the business better so in terms of
the impact of low trust the two biggest
things that I see is one decreased
productivity so if your bosses and trust
you he's always going to be watching
over your shoulder making sure you're
doing everything exactly right exactly
as they want it and sometimes they're
going to try to do things themselves
because they don't trust you to be able
to do it so there's a big drop in
productivity because you're too busy
watching each other instead of just
worrying about what you're supposed to
focus on the second impact that I think
of load trust is when you have really
low morale in the company so hit your
bosses and trust you right if you're
your person right in front of you
doesn't trust what you're doing you're
not going to be really happy working
there right if you don't trust the
people who are working under you then
you're also probably not gonna be really
happy working there so you want to work
at an organization where everybody does
trust each other so people going to
start looking for other jobs the morale
is going to be really bad if there's low
trusted and organization what can you do
about that so two things one you don't
know if you're managing people yet or
not for the people who are above you you
have to earn their trust so think about
your boss for them to trust you you have
to earn it you can't just say hey trust
me I'll get it done when people say
trust me you know you don't really tend
to want to trust them so you have you
have to earn it right Trust has to be
earned so whenever they give you a
project try to go above and beyond do it
faster than they expect do it higher
quality than xpect think of other ways
to make the project better
just what your you've been assigned and
you'll be the one on your team that
everybody trusts because you always do a
really good job so you have to earn that
and think of ways that you can always go
above and beyond to earn their trust in
this if you have a business it's the
same thing to earn the trust of your
customers can't say hey trust me you
have to prove to them that you're going
to over-deliver on expectations you
deliver it faster cheaper better then
you said you would and you're going to
earn a lifetime of trust from them if
you're managing people and you worried
about earning the trust of the people
below you show them trust first but if
you can show that you trust them they're
going to want to trust you so try not to
be a big micromanager I try not to
breathe down their necks and really push
them on timelines yes you have to get
their job done but try not to be
overbearing to the point where they feel
like you don't trust them if you show
that you do trust them then they're
probably going to work even harder
you'll probably be surprised by how hard
they were and they're going to start
trusting you as well and it's going to
help the entire company so I hope that
answer your question if you guys liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below and I'd also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below the video and stay
tuned to the next episode
you